oh that's really good
[Music]
hello I'm Lucy Hale and I'm Grant Gustin
and we are going to attempt to draw our
dogs
from memory but here's a fun fact I have
two Maltipoos that are small and white
and you have three small white fluffy
dogs as well whatever picture I draw
will be entertain all three of my stuff
I only know jet what are your other two
names rookie and Nora Sookie rookie yeah
I know okay
Ethel and Elvis correct okay we have one
minute to do this let's
[Music]
I don't even know like dog Anatomy like
right now okay are you doing over there
just a little chunkier than that's all
it looks like
I did this because these look like balls
it's really bad
[Music]
oh that's really good
crying so this is obviously Ethel yeah
and this is obviously
you practice
you brat he's been up all night doing
this you're a perfectionist I know you
did you wanted to make me look fast I
don't want this framed because it kind
of looks like my LV this is what I do
with outfits oh this is very cute
two grand
kids
what is it again
it's nice doing business with you I
actually really think this is adorable I
was gonna frame it put in my house maybe
he would
um it looks good it's really good could
you tell them more detail like your
favorite part about it I'm trying not to
describe that's a little too much detail
I didn't get a close look but if you
look at her too long can I explain so
Ethel's more poodles so she's a little
fluffier so it's fluff to remind in the
gutter I I look I said she looked like a
cactus yeah definitely and then Elvis is
more Maltese and he's got straighter
hair yeah linguine yeah and then what's
this
yeah okay so Grant definitely practiced
because this isn't a first go like I
know I know enough about him now that
like he likes things to be perfect
that's true but I didn't practice I
haven't drawn anything there's like a
stippling he's shaded no so I used to be
very good at drawing but I haven't drawn
in like 15. you're a driver you're an
artist 20 years okay our drawings might
be really good but I think our rom-com
is better so check it out
evening